the 1980s was an excellent decade for
Fantasy films but not because they made
a ton of cash many that have since been
lauded as cult classics utterly failed
upon release like croll an ambitious
mishmash of fantasy science fiction and
mythology genres croll tells the tale of
prince cwin who must recruit a squad of
Heroes to help on his quest to rescue
Prince Lisa from a fortress of Alien
Invaders these men follow no man but me
and I follow no man at
all would you follow a king croll failed
to woo audience es upon release and it
bombed pretty hard the estimated
production budget was around $47 million
that's a lot of money for a new
intellectual property costing the studio
significantly and ensuring no sequel
would see the light of day after it
returned just $16.9 million at the box
office today koll is a beloved Colt
classic and while it has its detractors
it also boasts a huge fan base the film
features then Cutting Edge visual
effects and has a fantastic score by
celebrated composer James Herer